en el vídeo anterior hicimos la primera
parte del inciso a ahora vamos con la
segunda parte entonces en la segunda
parte del inciso a nos dice calcula el
número de moles de teno que se
producirían si la reacción de
deshidratación se completará bueno esta
es la reacción de deshidratación y nos
dicen que empezamos con cero punto 200
gramos de etanol
entonces si empezamos con cero punto 200
gramos de etanol y calculamos cuántos
moles de etanol es esto sabemos que por
cada molde etanol bueno si la reacción
de deshidratación se completará por cada
molde de etanol se produce un molde de
teno y un molde agua entonces primero
vamos a calcular cuántos moles de etanol
hay aquí y después podemos decir ok si
esto reacciona completamente tendremos
esos moles de teno entonces hagamos eso
vamos a ver
el etanol etanol empezamos con cero
punto 200 gramos y queremos convertirlos
en moles entonces necesitamos
multiplicar esto por algo que tenga
gramos en el denominador para cancelar
los gramos y moleste en el numerador
entonces cuántos gramos tiene un molde
de etanol bueno eso ya nos lo dijeron
antes mire aquí nos dicen que el etanol
tiene una masa molar de 46.1 gramos por
mol entonces la masa molar del etanol es
de 46.1 gramos por mol o dicho de otra
forma un molde tiene una masa de 46.1
gramos y entonces haciendo esto nos
queda 0.2 cientos entre 46.1
los gramos se cancelan con gramos y nos
quedan moles entonces esto es igual a
estamos tomando tres cifras
significativas que dividiremos entre
tres cifras significativas entonces esto
es igual a vamos a ver 0.2 no escribiré
cero cero porque no es necesario en la
calculadora entre 46.1 y esto es igual a
cero punto 0 043 y como quiero tres
cifras significativas entonces vamos a
redondear lo a 43 40.00 434 entonces
esto es igual a 0.00 434 moles
ok entonces ya vimos en la reacción que
si tenemos este número de moles de
etanol si reaccionan todos estos moles
tendremos el mismo número de moles de
teno entonces vamos a ponerlo así si la
reacción de deshidratación
si la reacción de deshidratación ocurre
por completo
cada molde etanol
cada molde de etanol
se convertirá
se convertirá en un molde eterno
este no y un molde agua
un molde agua entonces 0.00 434 moles de
etanol entonces
0.00 434 moles de etanol
moles de etanol producirán el mismo
número de moles 0.00 434 moles
moles de este no entonces si la reacción
ocurre por completo estos son los moles
que se producen pero como lo que
obtuvimos en realidad es menor a esto
eso significa que la reacción no se
completó ahora vamos con el inciso b en
el inciso b nos piden que calculemos el
porcentaje de rendimiento de teno en el
experimento bueno el porcentaje de
rendimiento es simplemente lo que
obtuvimos entre lo que obtendríamos
idealmente si la reacción se completará
entonces el rendimiento es igual a lo
que obtuvimos que fue lo que calculamos
en la primera parte entonces
0.00 264 moles
entre lo que obtuvimos entre lo que
obtendríamos idealmente si la reacción
se completará entonces entre 0.00 434
moles y esto es igual a vamos a ver 0.00
264 entre 0.00 434 y esto es igual am si
tomamos en cuenta tres cifras
significativas es igual a cero punto 608
o también podemos decir que es igual a
60.8 por ciento entonces aproximadamente
obtuvimos un rendimiento del 60.8 por
ciento